so this is a case that I think provides
us with a helpful illustration of the PC
mob and how it operates and why it
operates the way that it does the CEO of
gonna make sure I turn my mic on I did
but you probably already knew because
you could hear me
the CEO of Papa John's John Schnatter or
Schneider force matters anyway we'll
just call him Papa John Papa John was
forced to resign this week after saying
the n-word during a conference call a
few months ago and this happened I think
it happened back like in April or May
and it's just now coming out for some
reason so he resigned he also resigned
from the University of Louisville's
Board of Trustees the MLB canceled a
promotion that it was supposed to be
doing with Papa John and I believe I
also saw that a a gymnasium named after
him in his hometown is now being renamed
all because of all because of this and
after all of that the the final
penitential act is that he's going to be
strapped to a donkey and covered in
pizza sauce and sent out into the
wilderness to be devoured by wolves but
even that will not be enough to a swage
his guilt for saying a word and what was
you know why did he say it's it's being
reported that Papa John used a racial
slur and think about the phrasing there
he used a racial slur but
what actually happened is that he was he
was having a conversation with a
marketing agency and they were talking
about the NFL and racial issues and so
in that context he pointed out that the
founder of KFC would often say really
terrible things about race and yet never
faced any backlash for it and so Papa
John said well Colonel Sanders called
black people the n-word only he didn't
say the n-word he actually said the word
itself so he was he was quoting Colonel
Sanders
and and not in a positive light but as I
said the media is reporting that Papa
John used a racial slur
which is you know that's like if that's
saying that he used it when all he was
doing is it was he was quoting somebody
else but saying that he used it that'd
be like if if I if I was trying to tell
you about the dangers of heroin
addiction and in the effort to educate
you I pulled out a heroin needle and I
showed it to you and said this is what a
heroin needle looks like okay you don't
wanna you don't want to inject this into
your body and then later on you told
everybody that you caught me using a
heroin needle which it's true in in one
sense I was using it I mean I was using
it in an effort to educate you about it
but it's not true in the sense that you
are clearly implying in an effort to
slander me and so when the media reports
that Papa John used the racial slur
they're obviously trying to imply in the
headline that he was saying it himself
not as a quote but in an effort to and
communicate his own racism and this gets
even crazier because during the call
apparently Papa John was yeah like I
said they were just talking about Ray
said he he was he mentioned some of the
racial violence that he saw growing up
or heard about growing up and again he
talked about this in the context of
condemning racism but some media reports
have taken that and they've said that
well John Schnatter use the racial slur
and described graphic scenes of violence
against African Americans obviously
trying to imply that this was some kind
of like Michael Richards racist meltdown
when it was nothing of the sort
I've even seen some leftist blogs
accusing him of launching into a racist
rant rant that I mean that's like if I
walked into your house and I said hey
it's a nice day outside and then later
on you told all your friends that I
barged through the door ranting about
the weather
it's just
there's it's not a rant and there's
nothing racist about it but but here's
the thing
in reality we all understand
in that context there was nothing racist
going on but according to the rules
according to the arbitrary social rules
that our culture has set up saying a
word saying that word at the spatula in
any context is enough to make you racist
so Papa John is now a secondhand racist
he he flew he came too close to racism
and thus became racist himself it was it
was it's like some kind of plague or
disease that he contracted by coming too
close to it
right by quoting a racist he became
racist even though the intent and the
context were not racist and were
actually anti-racist still he became
racist by some kind of some kind of
sorcery this is this is it's it's it's
it's like Harry Potter or is it so it's
a magical spell where if you if you say
a certain word it has this effect to
transform so I don't know I've never
seen a read Harry Potter but because I
have what do you call it good taste but
it's so maybe in Harry Potter he says a
spell and someone turns into a frog or
something so with now if you say this
word it's like a magical spell that
turns you into a racist it turns you
into a racist frog traditionally you see
outside of Harry Potter and outside of
the fevered minds of leftist that's not
how human communication works no usually
intent and context are very important
they are in fact indispensable aspects
of communication in that you cannot
analyze or understand what someone's
saying unless you have also also taken
into account the context in which they
said it and their intention behind
saying it so the words themselves also
matter but you can't evaluate somebody's
words without understanding the intent
and context behind them
this is one of the reasons why text
messaging that can be so confusing
because often with a text message all
you have are the words and you don't
have intent you don't have context you
don't have tone because with the text
message people don't usually take the
time to to write full sentences that may
also communicate all that stuff so they
just you just have a few words to go on
and that's why you could read a text
message and it could simply say okay and
oh the word okay could seem like this
passive-aggressive or angry thing
because you don't have especially if
there's a period but we all know that
anytime you send a text a a one word
text message with a period
his passive-aggressive I think we all I
think we all should understand that by
now but there's some people still seem
not to the problem though is that the PC
mob they want to treat everything they
treat all communication like a text
message where they take the words
themselves separated from intent and
context and they analyze those words on
their own kind of in a vacuum
and the n-word especially is treated
like this word that somehow transcends
intent and context it is I guess
probably the one word in the English
language that is just beyond intent and
beyond context and so it carries with it
this this mystical power to to turn into
racists all who happen to utter its
syllables well of course I got to back
up for a minute
it can turn you into a racist if you say
it provided you have a certain skin
pigment pigmentation so if your skin
looks like mine and you say this word
regardless of context or intent than
your racist but if your skin is darker
than mine and you say the word then it's
not racist
those that's the rule
those are the ingredients so skin
pigmentation a lighter skin pigment
pigmentation combined with these
syllables arranged in this particular
way create racism that's the that's
nobody can explain how the process works
that way but we've all just decided that
it does and it's madness of course
words are not actually magical spells
words are just words words themselves
cannot be racist a word is just a word
it can't be anything it's just the it's
just a word intentions can be racist
people can be racist
but if a non racist person with a non
racist intent says a word well then
there's nothing racist about the word no
matter what ii heard was
that's how it works
but we've what we've done is we've
turned the English language into this
kind of game where certain words have to
be avoided by certain people for reasons
that nobody can really justify and if
the word is said by the wrong person
then they're gonna face the prescribed
penalty just because that's the way it
goes so so in in monopoly if you roll
doubles three times in a row in one turn
you go to jail why well just because
that's the rule of Monopoly there does
that mean it's no other reason for it
besides that's just how you play
Monopoly and in life if a person with a
light skin color says this word in any
context they lose their job why well
just because that's just that's just
that's those are the rules
that's all you know that's that's why
you just how we play the game now to be
clear
not arguing that white people ought to
be able to say the n-word okay I have no
interest in saying and I I think it's a
nasty word that nobody ought to say I do
not have within myself any deep desire
to say it there are certain words that I
do have a desire to say that sometimes
I'll even just say if there's nobody
around just because they're fun to say
like flabbergasted for instance is a
word like that but the n-word is not is
is is not a word in that category so it
is a vulgarity like many other
vulgarities and I think if it's best if
we all try to avoid vulgarities and
profanities but I also think it's
completely insane that even now as I
speak I have to find ways to refer to
the word without saying the word itself
for fear that my very livelihood could
be destroyed should I make the mistake
of articulating the actual word that I'm
already conveying to you by using
euphemisms for it I think that's crazy
and we all know that it's crazy and yet
there are people probably watching this
video and they're just there waiting for
me to slip up because I'm talking about
the word so much and they're waiting to
get me on the technicality am I gonna
slip up and say the word itself and then
oh he said it his life's over take his
job away he's done
that's just that's not how society is
supposed to work
and it's purely semantics anyway and I
you know I really I think this when it
comes to not just the n-word but but
honestly any word that we we say oh the
the F word the S word the it's all kind
of dumb because if I say the F word or
if I say the n-word I am still conveying
the word to you right if I say if I say
to you the phrase the F word if you're
an adult I have just put that word into
your head have I not I've communicated
it to you I have successfully
communicated the word to you without
saying it so what was the point of not
just saying it
I am causing you to think it I mean
isn't this what it mean to communicate
for me to communicate with you what that
means is that I'm I'm taking a thought
and I'm taking words that are in my head
right these I that are floating around
in the ether in my mind and I'm taking
them and I'm funneling them through my
vocal cords and then I am putting them
into your mind I'm trying to get
thoughts from my mind into your mind
that's what it means to communicate and
so if I have communicated the n-word to
you then what what's what's the
difference between saying the N word and
thus communicating the N word and
actually saying the word itself and thus
communicating the word itself either way
I am communicating the same word am I
not
so what we're saying is it's okay to
communicate it to convey it to put it
across yet it's not okay to actually say
the syllables themselves because the
syllables themselves have this magical
power I guess it's just it's so
the only time that this whole game makes
sense to say oh the the blank word
rather than just saying the word the
only time makes sense is when there are
children around who maybe have never
encountered this word and so you're
trying to you know spare them for a
while the inevitable process of them
being corrupted by these vulgarities but
when you're around adults and they all
know the words you're talking about what
is the point of dancing gingerly around
it when in the end the result is the
same because I have put the word in drag
and
and now as I'm saying this and I wrote
about this yesterday and there were
people who accused me of cowardice
because
they said well well why don't you have
the courage of your convictions I mean
just come out and say it your intention
isn't racist you're talking about the
word we're all adults here
you think people should be able to talk
about a word without dancing around the
word they're talking about you think
that we should have to follow these
completely arbitrary and ridiculous
social customs of avoiding certain words
in any context whatsoever so why don't
you go first then just come out and say
it
well I'll tell you why maybe I am a
coward I don't know
I take this I'm not willing to have my
whole life destroyed over it that's why
it's always been clear to me that to do
this job this job you know if you're
gonna have a job where you're getting up
publicly and giving your opinions and
taking stands and so on if you're gonna
do that you have to be willing to lose
it all you have to be willing to lose
the job if you're gonna have this job to
do it effectively and to do it with
integrity you can't be too attached to
it and you have to be willing to face
potentially a backlash that could end
with you being fired or potentially even
worse consequences and I've always
realized that and I've accepted it and I
am willing to face that penalty if need
be and plenty of times in the past I
have said things that I thought maybe
could destroy my career in my livelihood
potentially and there have been a few
things that almost did but then not
quite
but this is just not one of those things
you know because we live in an
environment where so many dumb things
can ruin you and there are so many dumb
arbitrary ridiculous rules that have
been set up by the PC brigade that you
know you have to exercise some prudence
you have to say to yourself is this
particular thing is this stand worth
losing everything for
and I think it really is cowardice if
you if you ask yourself that question
and you always come to the conclusion
that no it's not worth it because some
things are worth it but there's a reason
why the left there's a reason why they
take they like to take really petty and
insignificant things and attach this
huge significance to it so there's a
reason why they make these rules these
really arbitrary rules like this one
where don't say this word in any context
and then the penalty for breaking that
rule is catastrophic like you could lose
everything if you break that rule
and I think from the outside sometimes
we tend to look at that and we say
what's why
what do you care why are you doing well
because it's about control because they
know that they can control you
you know they know that if they say if
they take some really huge important
thing and they say well don't do this or
you're going to face this consequence
well there are people who will do that
because they're saying you know that's a
hill I'm willing to die on because that
is big that's important that's
significant and then you create martyrs
basically when you do that so the
smarter strategy from the LES
perspective is to take a lot of
different small things
and to say and and and to say well no to
set a lot of little small landmines
because then it's it's it's really easy
just to walk over them and not bother
with it another example when it comes to
language is is all this stuff with with
pronouns
where you know you're not allowed to say
certain pronouns you know if somebody
people have their own pronouns now and
they make up even fake pronouns and you
have to figure out what someone's
pronoun and refer to them by that
pronoun and and if you break this rule
especially in a professional setting you
could lose your job you could lose
everything
so it's a small stupid insignificant
thing to which they have attached a huge
penalty and so I think a lot of people
look at that and they say fine I'll just
play the game because it's not worth it
it's not I'm you know I'm not I'm not
gonna lose my job over this
personally I think when it comes to
manipulating language that is a hill
worth dying on because with that what
the left is asking you to do is telling
you to do requiring you to do is to tell
a lie when they say yeah this person's a
biological woman but refer to this
person as a he I think a lot of us will
just play the game and say fine I'll do
it because I don't want to you know if I
don't then I could the penalty is too
severe I think that is a hill worth
dying on though and potentially losing
your job over because to play the game
in that case is to tell a lie and when
the left can get you to tell lies for
them well then they they own you I mean
they have your soul at that point
but something like this with the n-word
it's no it's not telling a lie to just
say the n-word and to play the
ridiculous game and so and so I play it
but it is
I think we all do recognize that it is
just a game
and it is a game that has pretty severe
consequences and it did for John
Schnatter in this case who is uh who's
been completely I think unfairly
slandered and maligned and is now
suffering severe consequences for it
that's what it's like to live in a world
governed by the politically correct mob
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed